- La caravane de François
l'hôtel de ville de Lévis.
f f f f caquiste veut
faire du maire un allié
pour son trois
- Merci pour ton appui
sur le tunuauauauais!
- Même si le tunnel Québec-Lévis
est récl
résidents ici, il ne convainc
pas eseseses contribuables
québécois auprès de qui il faut
en
de 6,5 milliards de dollars.
ÇOIS LEGAULT,
chef, Coalition avenir Québec
- Ça va aider le transport
prendre 10 minutes.
GILLES LEHOUILLIER,
maire de Lévis
- Étant entendu que
les études vont venir.
étaients défavorables au projet,
qu'est-ce que vous allez????
- Je suis convaincu
qu'elles vont être favorables.
- Content de te voir l l l l l n
des priorités des citoyens
plus à l'est, comme ceux de
Rivière-du-Loup et de Rimouski,
où François Legault s' L L L L ,
il répète une fois de plus
que les études qu'il détient
nuiront à l'acceptabilité parce
qu'une mise à joul'l'l'l'l'l'l's
semble toujours actuel.
- C'était... une étude
sur un lien à l'est. m m m m m n
ceilililille à centre-ville.
- L'étude en question est,aiaias
projets d'infrastructure
semblables au troisième lien,
expliquant de manière
les impacts souvent observés sur
le développement rtitititiel,
commercial et agricole.
- Vous avez pe
M. Legault?
- J'ai peuieieieien!
- Mais il persiste et signe :
hors de
des études réalisée
avant dédédédémie.
- Quand l'étude va être bonne,
qu
au début de 2023,
a a a a la publier.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
QuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQé
le projet avant même d'avoirdese
du projet, c'est gênant!
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
- Tout ça, est-ce que c'est
juste basé sur des maquettes?
- Les études ont été payées
par des fonds publics,
rappellent ses adversaires.
chef, Parti québécois
- Il y a 28 millions de dollars
derrière ça, puis on sait
toujours pas c'est quoi.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
- C'est surtout le reflet
de la manière de gére
de François Legault.
- Même si la pression s'accentue
pour dévoiler les asasasasasasas
l'intention d'en faire
une diversio s s s sa campagne,
surtout pas dans la région de
Québec, où la course s'annonce
serrée. nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnt
après l'élection. V V V Véroniq,
Radio-Canada, à Lévis